randal what do you think of our draft
fix there well I don't think there's any
Callaway golfers left to pay or III
started to say hello friends I'm gonna
be not gonna be I'm not gonna be around
for the you know the the the Jim Nantz
contest but I want to listen to that Jim
Nantz gotcha all right the guy we have
right out of the gate is pretty
spectacular but you know Nance didn't
win two years ago Nance didn't win the
sound alike contest he finished second
in Nats himself didn't win yeah that's
how tough it is and I think I need to
practice I don't think I'm low I mean
just hello friends you got Adam you the
music's plan the birds are chirping
you're welcoming people you gotta come
up with a tagline for a victory pot
something you know emphatic no you don't
have to do that but it's open to
interpretation
okay you got you got 364 days to
practice I'm gonna practice okay who's
your pick Justin Rose is my pick I
enjoyed listening you guys it's a hell
of a year for the format you just had
because there's about 15 guys you could
make a check make an argument for so
yeah but I just enrolled for me I mean
he's he's better than he is like or
better than he was last year and a lot
of key elements and and significantly
better in one which is putting he spent
his entire career as a mediocre to well
poor Potter basically and now he's one
of the best putters on the PGA Tour when
it comes to you know looking at the
expectation level with Tiger and the
expectation level is it too high
well I don't think so he's 114 majors
and if his name wasn't tired and we
didn't know anything about him and we
saw somebody finished 12th 2nd 5th in
their last three starts who had you know
won a lot of major championships we
would this guy's got a legitimate chance
you know I think they might be a little
high though when you consider you know a
lot of people are picking him to win
this week I wouldn't pick him to win
picking me to contend but he's just it's
just not good enough with the driver and
like I know he didn't drive a ball that
well in 2005 but in 2005 he could draw
the ball and keyholes and did you know
even though he didn't hit that many
fairways hit over 70 percent of the
fairways on the right to left holes
which are the key holes really and he's
just not not able to do that right now
and I'm curious to see how he gets
around I'm curious to see how he'll hit
his tee shot on to because he's not
about to try to hit a draw there I'm
curious that his tee shot on 5 9 10 13
14 14 gives him fits even the other day
when he was making the Eagles and on the
back nine Eagle 13 15 he got up on 14
just blow away right so you know what
those holes are you know he'll miss two
or three of those drives and the winter
won't that'll be the difference yeah it
comes down to those par fives you got to
win those par fives but when's the last
time you played Augusta 1999 so it's
been damn near 20 years wait nobody's
invited you to play yeah I did actually
have an invitation I just wasn't able to
go and I had another invitation a couple
of weeks ago but you know working life
getting away and I haven't been able to
go but but I definitely want to get back
I missed a little putt on the last hole
and the 99 masters about two feet and if
I had made it I'd have finished 11th and
gotten obviously I've been invited back
next year
but I don't regret a lot of things and
my golf at all I had I had a hell of a
run I enjoyed it I got to go play all
these great golf courses not I just for
free but I got paid a lot of money to do
it but I'm still pissed I missed that
two and a half footer on the last hole
you know I'd love to deny there's no
place like Augusta
I'm sure you've played it yeah I played
twice in
it was you know what's strange about it
and I and I draw the ball so 13 yes 13 I
was I was able to birdie one day 15 I
was able to birdie one day 12 I was able
to birdie one day and then the other
days on those holes it was ugly
I put it in you know twelve I go there
and I you know you're trying to read the
wind and you got I got a 7-iron then I
go to an eight then I go back to a seven
then I put it right into the creek so
you know yeah Tigers demeanor is kind of
interesting now I was asking Mike Tirico
about this when he did his interview it
almost feels like Tiger is is realizing
I got another chance my kids are
watching me how am I not able to enjoy
this like don't be afraid to enjoy this
instead of having that you know the
blinders on and you know cutthroat
cutthroat Tiger you see that I think I
know I absolutely do you know as much as
I'm enjoying his golf I'm enjoying the
way he seems to be enjoying himself this
is I think the Tiger Woods everybody
just wanted to see forever you know he
comes in he's he actually has fun with
the media he seems sincere you know and
they you know even though the other day
he got kind of a curveball question and
and he didn't he didn't blow up about it
or anything he just navigated his way
through a beautifully I think he in this
downturn I'm guessing I mean some of his
friends are my friends but I think he
found the value of a friendship and in
these dark times his I really do I think
he leaned on him and I think he found
the value in it and I think he also
found a valuing and and a lot of support
having a lot of support around him so I
think he's drawing from that I've
enjoyed the live from and you know be
nice to thank to Frank and you know
Thank You Brandon I'll be watching you
guys take care that's Brandel Chamblee
Golf Channel analyst and part of Golf
Channel's golf central live from the
Masters coverage for more Dan Patrick
show too
it's channel 239 on DirecTV or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]